you
hi everyone is cherrymon chest calm and
I'm gonna do another group of three
puzzles and hopefully not take as long
as I did last time if you're familiar
with the last puzzle in this series yeah
it took a while okay so let's see we're
playing as white in this one my eye is
immediately going to rook to d6 and
we're really really close to checkmating
black with King to c6 to follow rookie
six King here and he has no moves from
that position so yeah I think rookie six
King here king c3 another thing to know
is I believe I've actually had this
puzzle before clearly I'm not recalling
the solution right away but this
nevertheless is capturing my attention
it's luring the king up the board to
where these pawns can eventually can
eventually contribute hmm Brooke II six
is there something better as a start
another good forcing move it's worth
noting that should it be blacks move
there's no move that could be made that
would give check so silent moves in
other words as a start to this puzzle
may very well be available but yeah I'm
still looking at this rip to e6 King c5
king c3 the only way to stop b4 mate
would be to play a five and if we're to
try let's say a three with b4 and mines
next a four could be played which would
stop B for me at least for the moment
and I don't know rookie six king c5 King
C 3 a 5 this idea of B 3 a 3 B 4 that
may be too slow so um could be it could
be correct
I'm gonna look for something a bit more
forceful let's see oh you know maybe I
could change the move order I was
wondering about beef or instead of
rookie right away although on beef or
there is no g5 which would cover the g6
square however however okay I think I am
getting this one now the move b4 is
threatening to different maintenance I'm
glad I caught that v4 threatens rookie
six check mate and also night be 5 so
unbe for Knight g5 that defends only one
of the two mates so I think that that's
it
the King has no legal moves after b4 so
yeah you can't stop Knight b5 and rook
to e6 so this must be correct one
silent move to start that is correct and
now we have just rook to e6 and that's
me alright not too bad on that one so
that one's really coming down to move
order quite tempting to play rook e6
king c5 King's c3 but that a5 idea
mm-hmm you know makes it difficult to
pursue a mating attack but just
switching the move order you have two
moves in mind a b or b a you have to
really test out both okay let's try
huzzle - okay hmm
team black here alright how's the
material situation balanced
this square here has my attention f3
since two or more pieces can make use of
it in an intersection square h2 has
pressure on it this is maybe a
vulnerable point because why exactly one
attacker one defender hmm there might
actually be something involved with this
square on Queen takes h2 right away King
takes his forced Knight g4 and if King
h1 the bishop is in a pin we could
follow up with rook h6 mate hmm okay I'm
on to something here once again
questioning move order a little bit I
think this might be the start Queen
takes h2 taking the night here white
would just take the bishop on b7 maybe
there's even f4 so I think that's going
in the wrong direction
that was certainly look at this first
quite forcing only one reply Queen takes
King takes and now I wonder if it would
be rook h6 or Knight g4 as the next move
I think if Knight g4 um Oh actually what
am I talking about Queen takes King
takes Knight here there's King to g1
that's silly
there's no mating attack there okay yeah
for some reason I was thinking that King
had to go to h1 I was blind to the King
simply return to g1 let's scratch that
but what about a move like Knight g4
instead of Queen takes h2 oh no no no no
no no no no no uh-huh
hang on a second let's not lose hope on
this h2 square
yeah um I think there is still something
involved with that one that is related
to H 2 and F 3 Queen takes here King
takes rook H 6 and now in that position
if King G 1 we actually play Knight f3
check forcing Bishop takes and then
Bishop takes f3 threatening made on each
one and there's only one way you could
stop that me to play Queen G 2 or Queen
h3 on Queen G 2 there would follow rook
takes rook check rook takes rook and
only move unless the Queen wants to come
back here but in which case we'll play
rook H 1 so basically we're going to
take as many times on this square as we
can until we force Queen back to f1 and
then we give rook h1 mate
although that's actually off as well
because I'm forgetting my rook is on h6
and we no longer have two rooks on the
e-file I feel like I'm still in the
ballpark here something something with
these moves Knight f3 and although maybe
maybe not because there's some back rank
issues as well if I'm considering this
Knight check and we're coming over to h6
get mated
okay I have to come up with something
else
I guess hmm let me just look at this
once more Queen takes King takes rook h3
King g1 kingi one Knight f3 Bishop takes
Bishop takes rook takes rook as me let's
not do that
hmm okay I'm not sure what other
candidates to consider here an immediate
Knight f3 check really isn't working I'd
have three bishop takes and there isn't
anything happening on e1 nothing bad for
white if we're taking on e1 they have it
covered enough hmm
if a Knight g4 just threatening here um
oh wait a second is it just one of these
things where we take the bishop first
and then take the knight oh man is that
really what it is just simply you know
because I was saying initially if we
take the knight to take our bishop how
about we just take here first and then
take the knight because when we take
here you can't take the rook or anything
you have to recapture because we're on
the Queen oh man maybe that's what it is
material eyes maybe too excited about
that square huh Bishop takes King Queen
takes oh wait a second
Bishop takes Queen takes we could
actually then play Knight f3 and that
would win the house then we would have
something against the e1 rook and maybe
even the Queen and some line could even
take the
night on d3 so Bishop takes Bishop Queen
takes we'd be met with Knight f3 check
alright I got that one and Bishop takes
Bishop King takes what would we do there
if Bishop takes Bishop King takes if
rook takes Knight if rook takes Knight
my concern is this F formal of taking
advantage of the pin as soon as we take
this Knight rook on e it is unprotected
and this f4 move might show up
however Bishop takes Bishop King takes
rook takes Knight the King is on the
second ring so on f4 we can probably
play rook D to check and and then maybe
even made on h2 there run rip to d2 if
the King goes to G one we would take on
h2 so in this line with Bishop takes
Bishop King takes rook takes Knight f4
rook d2 check the king or excuse me what
white wouldn't need to not move the King
but instead block the check with rook to
e2 in which case we can do what we have
hmm we have a new square available for
the Queen in that line Bishop takes King
takes rook takes Knight f4 rook D to
check rook block there's now Queen to c6
check if we wanted to do that yeah I
think that that would be good actually
now
yeah cuz if the king goes to g1 we could
we could take the rook next and then
play Knight f3 getting out of the pin
with check and there would even be on
this Queen c6 check move there would be
on King h3 at the very least I believe
well how about just rook takes rook and
then we could even move the knight right
away because actually this Queen seeks
c6 move is doing two things hitting
white with a check and defending our
rook which means our knight on e5 can
then move so I think that that's the
solution let's go with it that is
correct and now riff takes Knight ah
they're not going any further but I
believe that that is the right idea let
me pull it up here and try and line up
as best I can so this here chop actually
let me reset this for a moment what does
it say in the analysis on the move does
it have anything about f4 not seeing it
just giving it real fast yeah let me
just highlight it out the idea that I
had in mind here with rook takes Knight
on f4 I believe it would be check and
then if King here here it's queen h2
mate
so the rook would have to block but now
we could insert this check and I don't
know let's say King a bit hesitant to go
here because of eventual Knight f3 with
checks so let's say King here you could
always take here and then you could
safely move the knight because your
queen is defending the roof maybe
there's something better but at the very
least white is our black is up black is
winning a minor piece with this
variation all right let's
tackle just one more hopefully not too
difficult
all right team light in this one hmm
okay well there's pressure on v2 at
first I thought this was a puzzle for
black because I saw the the pieces
bearing down on B - we can't do Bishop
takes Bishop because of Queen B - mate
okay as it stands right now material is
not balanced white is actually down upon
so let's see if Queen takes bishop queen
takes bishop
what's the follow up after that not
quite sure hmm okay this might be hmm oh
I think I see it yeah hmm so I'm
considering Queen takes Bishop Queen
takes Bishop this queen is in a really
good spot she's doing - very good things
keeping pressure on b2 keeping pressure
on the bishop so first dislodging the
queen inserting this rook to d5 move
then the queen basically could not move
to a square where she still exerts
pressure on b2 and the bishop on e4 this
would just result I believe in an even
exchange bishop for Bishop and I don't
see an ensuing attack with ideas like f6
or Rick to g1 they're pretty much easily
parried with g6 or on f6 there's even
Queen to g6
so I think this is an instance where you
first recognize okay Queen takes Bishop
Queen takes Bishop this or maybe even
viewing it as the Queen is in a very
good position look to first
inconvenience her and then this is
with queen takes bishop or maybe even
Bishop takes Bishop for example in rook
d5 if Queen here there's no more
pressure on v2 so you can now play
Bishop takes Bishop and the Queen
maintains control over efore and on rook
take our rook d5 Queen f6 there's
pressure maintained here but no longer
here so we actually have our Queen then
freed up so wherever there's no pressure
in other words if there's no pressure on
b2 we don't need our Bishop on b2 and we
could take Bishop takes g5 and after
rook d5 of Queen f6 there's no more
pressure on e4 so we don't need our
queen defending the bishop and we could
play then Queen takes g5 any tricky
stuff and just double checking here any
tricky stuff for black in the form of
night a night a3 or night to d2 both of
which give check I don't think so this
feels like it's a position out of the
Sicilian in situations where there's a
rook on ba dum I'm familiar with this
idea of night a3 pawn takes pawn takes
discovered check stuff not the case here
but anyhow I think this is pulled from
some Sicilian game yeah I'm pretty sure
it's rook d5 not really much else to
consider you know that must be it let's
do it
that is correct and depending on where
the Queen goes this is freed up no
pressure on e4 we now take Queen takes
Bishop and that should be it
okay just carrying it out once more okay
um not too bad
much quicker than the last group of
three which is nice if you're familiar
with that video I'm sure I'll always
remember that that puzzle that I
struggled with but anyhow I'm gonna end
it here got three puzzles in feel free
as usual to leave any feedback with this
video how did you do with these three
and I'll catch you the next one that's
how for now
take care bye
you